so let us start with our example suppose
that you go to a supermarket and start
observing customers arriving and leaving
from a given checkout counter assume
that there are two customers in the
queue when you arrive for simplicity
assume also that customers come one at a
time that there is a single queue and
that the customer in front of the queue
is the one getting served by the clerk
so what events of interest could happen
then a new customer could join the queue
this is an arrival or the customer
currently being served is done and
leaves departure or both events could
happen now for making a mall more
precise we need to specify the processes
of the customer arrivals and departures
and for that let's use some simple
discrete-time stochastic processes which
we have introduced before
so as usual we first divide time into
discrete time steps say in seconds here
N equals zero would correspond to the
time when you arrived for rivals it's
assumed that customers arrive according
to a Bernoulli process with parameter P
and you know at that time steps here
there is an arrival perhaps this
customer here six there is another
customer so during each time interval in
the pendency of what happened in the
past with priority P and your customer
arrives and with priority 1 minus P no
one comes it may be useful to think
about the following imaginary experiment
imagine that during each time interval
nature independently flips up biased
coin which has a priority P of resulting
in heads and 1 minus P in tails and
whenever heads is the result then a new
customer joins the queue so in our
example here here your 10 tails heads
tails tails tails heads tails etc from
the lecture on Bernoulli process
remember that this implies that the time
duration that means the number of time
steps between two consecutive arrivals
follows a geometric random variable
with parameter P so here in our example
that time duration of four is the result
of a geometric random variable with
parameter P so again once in the queue
customers wait their turn until they'd
start being served by the clerk and
typically when a customer starts to
check out the number of time steps it
takes to go through the anti process
will depend on many factors such as the
total number of items selected the speed
or the mood of the clerk and transyl
fourth we will model this variation by
assuming that the service duration of
any customer is the outcome of a random
variable in particular we'll assume that
the number of time steps it takes for
any customer to checkout is a geometric
random variable with a constant
parameter Q that is the same Q for each
customer so you might have a departure
here
that's correspond to that customer here
and another departure at time step 6
correspond to that customer it may be
useful again to think about another
imagine your experiment to represent
this service duration imagine the
following at the time a customer in the
queue becomes the one to be served that
customer starts flipping a biased coin
which has a priority queue of resulting
in heads and it does so independently
during each successive time steps until
heads appear for the first time which
then indicates that the checkout service
is done and that the customer can leave
so here in our example you arrive at
that time here this customer was being
served and during that time step that
customer flip the coin resulting in
tails tails tails heads that customer
now leads
the next customer start being served at
that time flips a coin tails heads then
that customer leaves again family we
will also assume the processes modeling
these arrivals and departures are
independent of each other now let us go
back to a made-up experiment and assume
that you have arrived at 6:45 p.m.
consider the following question what is
the probability that you observe a
customer leaving the checkout counter
during the first time step in our
example since there were at least one
customer in the queue that probability
is then simply Q however if that queue
had been ante when you arrived then that
priority would have been zero and have a
question what would Q be empty at 6:50
p.m. that means five minutes later well
it's hard to tell if the initial length
of the queue had been huge when you
arrived at 6:45 p.m. then the priority
that it will be empty five nights later
will be very small much smaller than the
priority in that case with two customers
initially or in that case with an
initial empty queue from these questions
and answers it looks like knowing the
number of customers in the queue at any
point in time not only provides a good
description of the system at that time
but it does seem to capture the critical
information we need in order to answer
questions about the future evolution of
the system so let us define the state of
our system as the number of customers in
the queue at each time step n and see
what we can do so here in our example
initially we had two customers
then time step 1 still to customers time
steps 2 we have 1 arrival so we have 3
customers I'm step 3 still 3 for 3 minus
1 we have a departure who's 2 so 5 was
still be to time step 6
we have level and a departure so we have
2 and so on and so forth
assume now that there is limited space
in the supermarket and that no more than
10 customers can be in the queue at any
point in time we can then give a
graphical representation of all possible
states for a system as follows our
system can be in 11 different states
from an empty queue with no customer to
a system at full capacity with 10
customers
let us now describe some possible
transitions between these states from
one step to the next suppose first that
the system is in state 2 and that one
new customer arrives and no one leaves
so you will transition from 2 to 3 and
this is what happened in this example
from time step 1 to time step 2 suppose
now that you are in state 3 and that a
customer leaves and no one arrives then
we would transition to state 2 like what
happened between time step 3 and 4
what else well you could also be in a
given state at one time step and stay in
the same state at the next step how it
can happen in two ways if there are no
arrivals and no departures in the next
step and that was what happened between
time step four to five here four to five
order is one arrival and one departure
like what happened between time Step
five and six a graphical representations
can be done with the help of arcs such
as here in order to complete our mall we
need to indicate the probabilities
associated with this transition so again
assume that you're currently in state
two with two customers in the queue the
probability of next going to state three
here with one more customer in the queue
is simply a Verity of having one arrival
and no departure on the other hand the
probability of being here and her going
in transition
next here correspond to one departure
and no arrival finally the system can
stay in state two like that when there
is one rival and one departure or no
arrivals and no departures this
transition probabilities would be
similar if the current state where one
three nine for the two extreme states
the transition priorities are a bit
different if you are in state zero the
queue is empty and you can go to state 1
with one additional customer with the
priority P or there is no new customer
coming and you stay in state zero
and if the queue is at maximum capacity
either you stay maximum capacity if
there is no service or you go down to
nine customers in the queue if you have
a departure
so one important fact when you are in a
given state for example state two and
you look at all possible transition
could go to three could go to one could
remain in two if you sum all the
probabilities P times one minus Q plus Q
times one minus P plus the stall
probability here PQ plus one minus P
times one minus Q you will get at all
probability of one similarly if you look
at this probability here this sum to one
and these probabilities sum to one it
simply says that from one time step to
the next if you consider all possible
transition probabilities they all have
to sum to one so in conclusion the so
called transition probability
Graff which is this representation here
provide a complete representation of a
discrete-time finite state Markov chain
model of our simple supermarket circuit
an example